more than three months ago House
Majority Whip Steve Scalise miraculously
survived an attempt to assassinate GOP
lawmakers on a baseball field in
Virginia today he returned to the job
for the first time since the shooting in
a packed house chamber filled with joy
then the Louisiana congressman delivered
an emotional address to his colleagues
Thank You mr. speaker
you have no idea how great this feels to
be back here at work in the people's
house when I was laying out on that ball
field the first thing I did once I was
down and I couldn't move anymore
as I just started to pray and I will
tell you it gave me an unbelievable
sense of calm knowing that at that point
it was in God's hands a lot of people
asked did this event change you yes it
changed me but not in the ways you might
think it's it's only strengthened my
faith in God and it's really
crystallized what what shows up as the
goodness in people I got to see that
goodness in people
Scalise thanked the Capitol Hill
officers who saved his life and
countless of others that day in June and
then he had a personal message for all
the lawmakers in that room when I come
back into this chamber here today it
just see in the faces of all of you it
just means more to me than you can
imagine so thanks for all of that love
and support we are the people's house
this is the place where these ideas are
supposed to be debated and we fight
through those issues but ultimately we
come together on whatever the board
shows us 218 if you can put the majority
together
that's what rules the day it's so
important that is we're having those
political battles we don't make them
personal I am so honored to be back here
in the house serving with you god bless
each and every one of you and god bless
the United States of America what a
special moment and a man who really just
fought for his life there were moments
there was very touch-and-go where people
really thought he wasn't going to make
it but he said through faith and prayer
and the courageousness dana of those
officers putting their life on the line
to be able to save him and the other
lawmakers truly a powerful moment I
think in a really impactful message to
say you know respect to our differences
we can debate
ultimately we have this system of
governance and incredible work also by
the healthcare workers the doctors and
nurses like the emergency room but also
the rehabilitation because it really our
news cycles go so fast it's hard to hear
this was actually only a two and a half
months ago Wow that the shooting took
place and of course it was so traumatic
and remember when President Trump and
mrs. and the first lady go to the
hospital to visit the question was was
he going to make it and the injury could
have severed an artery and this story
would not be as wonderful it is as it is
today so yes I think an amazing return
and you can see his colleagues all seem
genuinely happy to have him back and our
own Lauren fine who used to work here as
a producer is now his communicate as
press secretary for the Majority Whip
and has been working hard to make this
moment happen I thought it was flawless
it was fantastic so she did a wonderful
job it must have been her time here with
us on the five a great powerful moment
and you know he brings up the message
that you know that capital officers
saved his life and you know I have to
tell you thank God that they were armed
and there to be able to protect them
it's also amazing how strong he sounds
after two and a half months you know it
point it points out a really strange sad
reason for him being alive was that the
surgeons were able to save a gunshot
victim because they're so good at it now
I mean they've got a lot of practice in
DC and another good cut in other states
working on gunshot victims in the and it
reminds you the numbers of gunshot
victims could victims could be much
worse than they are now but it's being
covered by the fact that they're the
sturgeons are so good at saving lives
imagine the numbers of Chicago or in DC
so it's not a reduction really in
homicides but surgeons in tech
technology reducing murder so that's
kind of amazing to your point our new
cycle this thing would have been a huge
huge deal for a year yeah but it's like
seems like it happened up forever ago
because we're so constantly churning
through stories you know it's
unbelievable so happy to see my bet and
his family to my goodness so nice yeah
it was a powerful home and I'm not the
most devout guy but when he's talking
about prayer he's talking about people
coming together you just get the chills
running up and
down your spine he wasn't supposed to
survive that was a gunshot wound and
part of the body that's not really
supposed to sustain bullets like that
and he fought back now gabby giffords
also shot in the head I fought back
recovered bravely we talked about on 911
the anniversary the United flight 93
people that storm the cockpit or when
you look at Harvey people wrestling
other Americans out of the water into
safety it's those moments where you
really see the fighting American spirit
and it inspires people it inspires you
to come together as a fellow American
but now these moments are so few and far
between you we were united after 9/11
for a while and then Iraq tore us apart
the Scalise shooting a couple months ago
we had that moment where we reflected
about our rhetoric that's gone
especially after Charlottesville then
Harvey hit and we looked at the Texas
resilience and then now of a sudden
we're talking about the divisive nough
Sonny lers so people just need to
recognize this country is much stronger
when we're together and not divided
alright so the message of unity I've
wanted healthy discussion and debate
that ultimately at the end of the day if
you can put 218 up and the majority will
rule but you know we can respect each
other in that debate process along the
way well absolutely I think that's
what's I hope that's the message people
take away from this because I think we
need more of it and oftentimes it seems
like you know division and anger rule
the day but in what it comes down to is
I think Americans do honor each other
and I love that when Scalise he did an
interview with 60 minutes yes in which
he talked about what the doctors did for
him at MedStar Washington Hospital
Center and he said in very humorous
terms they put Humpty Dumpty back
together again because he described all
the damage in that pelvic area and how
you know in fact he then later had an
infection and it took a lot of work and
a lot of time so looking at him knowing
him I can see he's lost weight but I
thought he looked much better than I
would ever have guessed I thought he was
going to look like a shell but no it
looks like Steve Scalise is still in
there and his spirits stronger than ever
he's a good Majority Whip yes in terms
of his his skills at being able to get
lawmakers to be all on the same page and
the president's gonna need that going
into the tax reform debate and I hope
they listen
a little bit extra closely now at this
point well god bless him and his family
and as Dana said the you know men and
women that saved his life in the
hospital and the capital officers as
well